dirigiéndose a la eucaristía en el
oscuro sótano iluminado por velas de su
iglesia es un ser gay espera
proporcionar consuelo a los que quedan
en liza chance que
allí no hay electricidad ni agua desde
hace semanas y celebrar oraciones en la
superficie es demasiado peligroso
condenándolos combates que resuenan en
la iglesia dañada pero también sin haber
buscado tradicionalmente la guía
espiritual de rusia el día conocer gay
dice que es imposible tomar partido
tenemos el hecho de hoy un hombre ruso
nací aquí y ucrania es mi patria quiero
que a este país le vaya bien pero no me
gusta nada es lo que está ocurriendo es
pura maldad texto fresco jetta tabúes
stilson
en una posición tenaz desde la invasión
rusa a la iglesia ortodoxa ucraniana
cortó el viernes los lazos con el pal
mercado ruso en una declaración de
varios puntos no estamos de acuerdo con
la posición del patriarca kiril de moscú
sobre la guerra en ucrania el consejo
condena a la guerra como una violación
del mandamiento de dios no matarás el
consejo ha adoptado la plena
independencia y autonomía de la iglesia
ortodoxa ucraniana este es el segundo
cisma tras la anexión rusa de crimea
algunos se separaron pero ahora con la
iglesia ortodoxa ucraniana rompiendo
lazos que se remontan al menos al siglo
17 marcó un momento histórico contra las
autoridades espirituales rusas en
particular contra el patriarca kiril
líder de unos 100 millones de fieles el
consejo ha denunciado su incapacidad
para condenar la invasión o prestar
ayuda a los ucranianos
objetivo de las sanciones europeas el
patriarca kiril se habría beneficiado de
sus estrechos vínculos con vladimir
putin